Spotlight on Brazil: USA team profile.
The USA bounced back from a first game defeat to Honduras in the final round of qualifying...
...to finish in first place and reach their seventh World Cup finals in a row.
In three of those knockout tournaments, the United States reached the knockout stages.
And that will be Coach Jurgen Klinsmann's aim of game,...
...as he contemplates the tough assignment handed to his team in Group G...
...which contains Ghana, Portugal and his own nation, Germany.
The US boss oversaw a morale-boosting 4-3 win over Germany in 2013...
...although admittedly, the Germans were below full strength.
Klinsmann himself has chopped and changed the American lineup,...
...but he's likely to rely on the proven talent...
...of former Tottenham and Fulham attacker Clint Dempsey,...
...Sunderland striker Jozy Altidore and Everton goalkeeper Tim Howard.